mostly you came in you said I like your
Thai I said I like your chest it's
really really nice and today you had a
clear strategy let's make a draw don't
take any risks in the classical chess
play some rapid and that ten plus five
portion I have to say you're a master of
that I think yeah well yeah I mean the
most important match was one from like
three four days ago
when I was still in the winners bracket
but it is what it is I mean I wanted to
play the classical game today but there
was simply no time to prepare any good
ideas any good Novelties with the
opening yeah also
the game yesterday was very taxing
mentally but it felt like from the match
that you just mentioned as being the
most important the first encounter
between you and Hikari you took some
information from that you understood
that in ten plus five you can outplay
him did you feel like that and was that
part of the strategy no well the
Champions bracket was important because
I didn't realize there was an extra ten
thousand I only found that out yesterday
but uh
yeah I mean you know I just uh as long
as I'm determined as long as there's a
chance I'll try to take my chance and
play my best chess I mean I think Hikaru
is still you know relatively the
favorite in in ten plus five or in Rapid
but uh
as long as I can put up a good fight
then I'm happy with that and guys join
the conversation absolutely well first
of all uh Wesley uh well done I mean you
did what you had to do uh you extended
the match for tomorrow yeah make it work
all right thank you very much for that
by the way we were talking about the
prize fund there and we were thinking
this is such a nice tournament having
you guys play just for the honor of the
event not necessarily for the variety I
mean and the commentators are going to
speed up what about your cash birth
birthday cash funds I I wanted to ask
you about the second game and when you
found the move Bishop F3 uh Christian if
you could bring that position to the to
to to the board and just share with the
viewers your thoughts at exactly that
moment because we thought the move
Bishop F3 was simply outstanding well I
thought
I was fine but maybe bishop G4 was
inaccurate and then I missed Queen A4
I'm not sure what's happening there but
um
yeah when he played when I played the
Knight E4 I already had lots of ideas
with Bishop F3 present like if Knight
takes maybe Rook takes Knight F5
and take on H4 take on e44 with the Rook
maybe 0.05 but take with the Rook Knight
F5 and then here I was already looking
at Bishop F3 or queen G5 but then nice
very nice move yeah but then as he was
thinking after Knight F5 my first
intention was Queen G5
on on the game during the game during
the game right
if you take on now instead of Bishop F2
oh instead of which My First Financial
Queen G5 but he's got the move F3 which
is really annoying and this was still a
very nice move Bishop to F3 I have to
say we were all very impressed yeah I
wasn't sure what if it works or not but
I didn't wanna I didn't want to wait to
float that and get out of played I was
already down the clock so I thought Play
Bishop F2 see Wesley congratulations big
match victory for you we'll see you
tomorrow I think